so the number one thing that I think
grpc has that might be different from
other things is real world usage
um but you might be thinking rest Json
all this stuff has plenty of real world
usage but
um the thing that I kind of want to
stress is that
um there are really good projects out
there that are both modern and mature
using grpc
um that are open source that you can go
read their code so examples of two that
I would Point people to are vitess and
my own spice DB
um
the like these projects kind of are
different because uh grpc kind of
crosses different language ecosystems
you can kind of see best practices and
things and extrapolate those workflows
regardless of what your your domain or
your project is
um unlike kind of rest apis where sure
if you're building a web app and you're
doing it in Ruby it makes sense for you
to look at maybe what folks are using in
the rails ecosystem but if you're
writing stuff in um if you're trying to
write I don't know a database software
it may not be useful to see how rest
apis are implemented in web apps for
example
um
so that's that's just my straw man
argument I guess
um kind of like the real world usage and
other systems
um but the super cool thing about grpc
is that you get to kind of see these
idioms and patterns that are used in
these mature projects
um you can straight up copy them
um but not only that because we have
open source and the core of the
ecosystem for grpc uh you can actually
kind of go into the pull requests and
commit messages for the software and
read the justifications behind the
decisions that they've made why are they
doing particular things why have they
chosen this
um maybe you'll see that like actually
this is a workaround for some other
Behavior or they're they're actually
addressing Legacy clients for example so
that can be nice warnings for you to be
like oh uh if you if you don't have that
Legacy maybe you don't need to do this
particular thing right
um but you get to kind of see these
mature projects and see what their
workflows are what tools do they do use
for example deprecating
rpcs or doing API versioning these
aren't things that you'll find in the
grpc documentation there's no one way to
do these things but if you look at all
these different projects that are mature
and kind of following the best practices
you can arrive at what you think that
solution should look like for your use
case in a well-informed way that you
might otherwise not be able to do
all right so
um now that we've kind of gotten that
one out of the way that was big number
one uh big number two is buff
um so buff is a fast extremely fast
protobuf compiler so it's an alternative
to protoc which if you're following any
of the tutorials or official
documentation for grpc that's the
compiler you're using
now the value for buff isn't so much in
the speed of the compiler but actually
the workflow that it provides so buff
was originally written at um well buff
is the spiritual successor of a tool
that was internally developed at Uber to
manage all of their apis
and the big value that I think that buff
gives you is an improvement over um
converting bash scripts to to do
workflows in in um in grpc and dealing
with these print-off definitions but
most powerfully it has static analysis
and linting for your definitions and I
think this is so important that I even
wrote a blog post about it that is
featured on Buff's website and if you
look at kind of like the last line of
text there that subtitle I call it the
first day of the rest of your life
because the second you create an API
um you're stuck with it now once people
start calling it you're going to have to
maintain it creating the code is just
the first step code typically outlives
you if you're working on a project that
is going to be serving customers
and so you might not always have Proto
experts available to you to help you
with design decisions so uh and honestly
it's hard to keep up with all the
changes necessarily but the nice thing
about buff is that once someone learns
what those best practices are if they
can codify it they will build it in as a
Lynch rule to buff and then everyone
who's using buff will get basically if
it's built into your Ci or just your
local tooling you'll be aware the second
you write the code that um
that you're either breaking you're
violating something
um or you're not doing the best practice
the really really really cool thing and
most useful thing with buff is actually
detects breaking API changes so it can
tell you if what you've changed versus
what you had changes the protobuf wire
format representation enough that you're
going to break clients that's incredibly
powerful if you're trying to figure out
how to move forward or do backwards
compatibility with new iterations of the
same API
and uh kind of like the the Big Value
here and the reason why I think buff is
number two is because if you are um if
you're maintaining rest apis for example
uh let's use the guiding guiding uh The
Guiding Light the North Star the
industry which is stripe um stripe has
basically uh clients that haven't been
touched that are still calling the same
apis perfectly compatibly 15 years later
um
but to do that they have to hire a whole
team to manage their API and they have
to write a bunch of custom tools and
typically doing integration tests
against their apis so they're actually
testing the API after all the code is
there and kind of like the complete
end-to-end experience versus a lot of
the same logic that they're testing when
you're using something like grpc any
kind of like RPC language that has this
IDL form that we can use static analysis
on we can catch
good amount of these problems the second
you write the right the actual
definition of the API we don't have to
write a client we don't have to generate
a client or anything like that we don't
have to like test it and to end in a
real system to to tell whether there's a
problem and you don't need to hire all
the engineers to build all of that stuff
for you and make sure you're maintaining
all of that if you just have a static
analysis tool that runs in your editor
or runs in your CI that does this for
you this is a huge window production if
you are not using buff but you're using
jrpc highly recommend you look into it
um so talking about tooling the next one
is a library so Google apis is
um basically a collection of shared
types from Google's protobuf uh apis
basically
um they had a whole bunch of services
that were using product buff externally
facing to the internet and they decided
to refactor basically and pull out all
the common types across those apis turns
out common types across Google apis are
also useful but they're probably going
to be common types across your apis as
well
so you'll see General patterns here for
error handling managing times and
durations key value pairs different data
structures like this
um and
the super nice thing about this is
actually depending on what language
you're running in there might also
already be a library that exists for
these types so instead of you having to
find your own new type for
timestamps for example Google already
has one for timestamps and their
timestamp library is going to convert
between that format and the standard
libraries time type that that is
built in your language Native in your
language so you get a lot of really easy
conversions
um between your native language types so
you can use all libraries you've written
and keep your all your code
um kind of like native to the language
and not coupled to part of
um
if you if you adopt uh some of the
Google apis so
um
the other warning thing here is that I
will say it's kind of tricky to know if
a project has overlooked Google apis or
deemed it
too much complexity and not worth
adopting so the reason why uh
traditionally a lot of folks won't have
adopted Google apis is because prior to
buff there weren't really good workflows
for importing libraries into
um your own protov off kind of
definitions and generations so now that
buff exists it's really easy to add a
dependency to something but prior to
that you would have typically vendored
it at a particular version which means
copying and pasting the code and
maintaining it yourself from that point
on so that's kind of error prone and
clunky and not a lot of people like
understand how
how to do the magical incantation for
the proto-c compiler Flags
so I'll uh a lot of people have actually
avoided using third-party dependencies
when it comes to protobuf and grpc but
that should no longer be the case so if
you see useful types in here I say go
for it
next in the same vein of trying to avoid
writing as much code as possible don't
worry if someone else has there's uh
this custom plugin which I'll get in the
custom plugins later spoilers
but product gen vality which basically
writes a validation method so you don't
have to
in your part about definitions you can
annotate fields and say for example you
have a light field and in a message and
you can actually annotate it and say
this field should never be more than 128
kilobytes
um or the string field should only
contain this strings that fit this
regular expression and once you've
annotated that you generate code that
gives you this validation method and if
you call this validate it throws an
error if all of those constraints that
you associate with those types in the
protobuf definition are not met this
supports a variety of languages the
Sports Go C plus plus Java python
um but I'm not sure if this exists in
all those languages but in go there's a
really nice middleware that you can use
that actually you slot into a server and
it basically returns early with an error
if any of the requests coming in are not
valid like the validation method throws
an error so that means you don't
actually have to manually even call the
validate method in your handlers to know
that every single request coming in
meets the constraints that you've
labeled uh you've annotated in your
product buff definitions incredibly
powerful stuff and you basically don't
get you don't have to write the code you
have way less room for human error and
making any mistakes in what can be
pretty sensitive stuff you don't want to
accept uh like Corner cases or very uh
very corrupted forms of RPC requests
right
so there's another project out here
called grpc Gateway originally written
by Johann bronhorst and uh what it does
is it works very similar to product gen
validate where you annotate your protos
but this time you annotate it with an
HTTP path and an HTTP method and it
generates for you a reverse proxy that
will sit in front of your grpc
application and actually convert Json
HTTP requests into
grpc requests and then talk to your
service and then your service will write
a response back to their reverse proxy
and then it will take that response and
convert it into Json HTTP and return
that to the client so that means your
client you can support Legacy clients
you can support environments that cannot
use grpc maybe they have they have like
some kind of memory restrictions because
they're an embedded system or anything
like that you can support all these
environments and not write code to do it
you can just generate that code
um
what's super cool about this is not only
can you generate the code to do that you
can also generate documentation for the
HTTP API it generates but also you can
use that
um that same exact generation tool to
generate clients so this is all using
open API if you're unfamiliar you can
Google that or Google Swagger which is
the thing that inspired open API but at
the end of the day What it lets you do
is have API documentation and even
generate clients for HTTP so what that
means is you can write a grpc service
definition
and have it generate both documentation
for grpc the grpc service itself
documentation for HTTP and the HTTP
service itself right services and
clients right for for both
um incredibly incredibly powerful stuff
supporting multiple protocols so it may
even be a better way of just writing and
maintaining rest apis at the end of the
day even if you choose to never use the
grpc apis or maybe your customers don't
or users don't necessarily use it as
much
so uh there's a really really cool thing
for go programmers here which is because
grpc Gateway is actually written and go
you can do this additional trick where
you can actually instead of running the
reverse proxy as a separate process as a
separate process um you can actually run
it in the same process
um so that it just calls directly into
your app like in memory
um but uh even cooler is you can
actually make them share the same port
if you're willing to sacrifice some
performance by using a trick where you
read the first couple bytes of a
connection and determine whether the
request is grpc or HTTP and then route
up accordingly internally to your
application so that's really really cool
stuff you can basically expose one
single port for your go service and it
can serve HTTP and grpc
all right
um I mentioned middleware a little bit
um and I think that like uh one of these
super super useful and most interesting
things about grpc is that you can
actually support client middleware
um so there there's uh when people think
of middleware they almost always think
of server side middleware they think of
adding on new Behavior or like
authentication or authorization into
kind of like their handlers and changing
the handlers in um in a server but um
what's super interesting about grpc is
it actually has middleware on both sides
um
and that is less common but extremely
powerful
um so powerful that I argue it kind of
alleviates the need for an API Gateway a
lot of the time
um like let's forget about all the rest
off I was just talking about like let's
get back into why why we like why we're
using grpc like let's take full
advantage of it
um with a single line of code we can add
authentication compression
um
modern observability LinkedIn logging
metrics and tracing we can do timeouts
rate limiting uh recoveries exponential
back off
um and like all this stuff is a single
line import into your client your client
um and you might be wondering well like
why why would I want that in my client
um
uh Google actually believes
um internally in kind of this philosophy
that is dumb Surfers more clients
um and the value that that has is it
lets you actually like iterate on your
design a lot on the client side
um you're going to do more work and it
may be a little bit more complicated but
it avoids you putting Behavior into this
server that you're going to then have as
Tech debt forever you'll have to be
maintaining that forever forwards
um so if you're not 100 confident that
but that is behavior that you need
server side first you should try to
experiment with a client side
and make a really really smart client a
great example of this is actually Kube
cuddle for a super long time in the
kubernetes ecosystem the kubernetes API
service was pretty basic and Coupe
cuddle when you did Coupe cuddle apply
it did all of this logic to figure out
what needed to be applied
um to the the actual
Etsy CD inside of kubernetes but
nowadays we have finally a lot of that
logic that was being done in apply
we came to the conclusion that this was
core logic it should actually be in a
server and now we have server side apply
in kubernetes right so this is an
example of that make the client really
smart until you know that this is core
behavior and then you can move that into
the server
smart clients highly recommended if
you're developing a service and you
don't know exactly what should be in the
server yet
um
so custom plugins I've mentioned a
couple plugins so far I mentioned how we
can generate all these different things
additionally
um so what a plug-in does is it is the
hook that generates code in a protobuf
compiler
um so for example when you generate your
protobufs in a particular language so
you use go for example
um that is a the go plugin and then
there's a gogrpc plugin which generates
your service definitions in go
um
when when I was talking about product
gen validate that generates your
validation methods
um that is an additional plug-in
um
uh when I talked about uh kind of the
open API and the different HTTP
um content that you can generate these
are additional plugins that you can
generate off of your protobuf
definitions but um what's really cool is
that uh we can write our own plugins
we're not beholden to just one of our
plugins because it's just already for
jrpc and product buff so if you see your
problem like these other projects that I
just mentioned you can fix that problem
and what's really interesting is you can
even address problems that you find in
the foundational plugins for example the
go Plugin or the um or the grpc plugin
for example the folks over at Planet
scale while developing the tests built
this project called VT protoboff what
they noticed was that when you are
writing
go code for grpc or for just part of
generally what you're doing is you're
actually using runtime type reflection
and go when you're encoding and decoding
um to two bytes to the protobuf wire
format and so uh that's really slow
um and they're trying to write a high
performance server so they realized like
hey we actually have all this
information ahead of time we know
because we have the definitions and
we're generating the code to do all this
stuff we know what the size of this
thing when it's encoded is going to be
statically and we know all these types
statically already why aren't we using
that information when we encode and
decode so what they did is they wrote
their own custom plugin that generates
the code that does all that so when you
use encode and decode like their
Marshall VT Marshall and vtn Marshall
you're actually not doing any reflection
and it's way more performant than the
built-in encoding and decoding that you
get with igrpc so even when you hit the
core
core like you you hit the boundaries of
what you can actually do with the core
technology it also gives you a door to
kind of like sidestep it and do whatever
you need just to just to solve your
problem so custom plugins are incredibly
powerful um
because uh there wasn't really a lot of
documentation or um really a
specification even around the input and
output that you kind of take to write
your own
um the buff folks have done great work
in kind of making this well more
well-known and building out an ecosystem
and packaging for this stuff I predict
in the future that the open source
ecosystem for
custom plugins will grow massively I
know that a bunch of companies actually
have pretty healthy internal plug-ins
that they they share among themselves
for some of the largest grpc shops but
really what we want is to build this
ecosystem and have have everyone feel
empowered when they they have an itch
they can scratch it
so but that my final my final feature is
the mystery box which is actually more
of a warning that I'm going to leave you
off with
um this is that uh while I did mention a
lot of the stuff super cool things all
done in the community it's actually
still really hard uh when you're in the
grpc ecosystem to figure out what is the
best practice you can look at some
really popular projects or really useful
projects where they describe uh kind of
like the value they're going to give you
and you can tell yourself hey that's
perfect that's exactly what I wanted but
it's really hard for you to know how
they're doing it or if they're still
maintained or if they're using all the
best practices
so for example if you're in the go
ecosystem there's an amazing Library
called GoGo protobuf it's incredibly
useful for many years unfortunately it's
end of life it's unmaintained it's using
an old version of protobuf you shouldn't
use it for new projects but the
functionality provided for many years
was Second To None it was incredibly
useful library for squeezing out more
performance and protobuf
um
and making different various trade-offs
actually depending on what domain you're
interested in using but there's also
kind of nowadays at least they have a
warning on it they fully admit that the
project is unmaintained and you should
look elsewhere but that may not be
obvious if you're not reading kind of
the readme but you're just looking at
documentation or looking at someone
else's code for example
ETD which is a super well known very
mature product it's critical to all
kinds of cloud native systems including
kubernetes itself
it uses Coco Proto buff
um what's what's a shame is that there
are very mature critical projects out
there but they're not necessarily modern
um so when a CD adopted grpc
um for I think it was apiv two either
API V2 or API V3
um they adopted All The Cutting Edge
stuff they it looked right it was Modern
it was great then but then they never
touched it
um which is a shame because it means
that if you are using modern protobuf
tooling and you go take the STD service
definition and then generate them you
actually probably can't talk that CD
with that because they haven't kept up
and updated the server side so there's
going to be incompatibilities there
which means that now they're losing a
lot of the benefit of the the grpc
ecosystem they're not able to actually
leverage all these tools and modern new
things have folks take their definitions
generate and run
and actually what you actually end up
doing in practice is you kind of have a
SCD specific client now like it's no
longer a grpc client it's an FCD client
because etcd speaks a particular flavor
of grpc that's old and bespoke
um it's really unfortunate and if you
kind of go out there naively thinking oh
this is a critical project they must be
doing it right I'm going to learn from
them copy what they're doing it you
might end up adopting the wrong things
unless you do diligence to make sure
that what you're copying is is right um
so that's my word of warning if you have
any other questions you can find me on
the social medias Twitter Mastodon
GitHub my company Zed actually has a
Discord where we discuss lots of Open
Source technology considering Space TV
itself is open source so if you have
questions about necessarily how we're
using grpc or you're interested in kind
of like tricks that we have or find
anything on the issue tracker related to
that feel free to join that and ask
questions there I'm also on the
kubernetes slack if you want to ask me
questions directly there or in the grpc
channel itself there so thank you for
your time